PETER STRZOK, McCABE, AND THE
WHOLE DIRTY LOT OF THEM.
>> Judge Pirro: JOINING US NOW
NOW, THE AUTHOR OF THE RUSSIA
HOAX.
GREGG JARRETT AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, SARAH CARTER.
I'M EXCITED TO BE DOING THIS.
HERE, WE HAVE JUST RELEASED THE
NEW THREE OH TWO.
WE DIDN'T EVEN KNOW IF IT WAS A
THREE OH TWO BECAUSE ON
WEDNESDAY WHEN JUDGE SULLIVAN
ORDERED IT BE TURNED IN ON
FRIDAY, WE DIDN'T GET IT ON
FRIDAY.
WE GOT IT TODAY AND IT'S HEAVILY
REDACTED.
THE THREE OH TWO FOR THE VIEWERS
IS BASICALLY AN INTERVIEW OF THE
INDIVIDUAL THAT IS TURNED INTO A
REPORT OF THREE OH TWO.
IT IS SUPPOSED TO BE DONE
CONTEMPORANEOUSLY WITH THE
REPORT.
NOW WHAT WE HAVE HERE IS, WE NOW
HAVE A AVERSION OF THE
JANUARY 24TH INTERVIEW OF
MICHAEL FLYNN.
SIGNED FEBRUARY, ONE VERSION IN
MAY, AND THEN ONE VERSION IN
AUGUST.
>> YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE VERY
FIRST ONE.
IT'S USUALLY THE MOST AUTHENTIC
AND HONEST.
AND THESE PROSECUTORS, THEY
TRIED TO PULL A FAST ONE ON THIS
JUDGE AND ED SULLIVAN WAS HAVING
NONE OF IT.
LAST FRIDAY THEY WERE SUPPOSED
TO BE AND THEY DELIBERATELY HID
AND NOTICED IT.
SO THAT PUTS -- THAT'S A
RED FLAG FOR THE JUDGMENT PUTS
HIM ON ALERT DURING TOMORROW'S
HEARING AND HE MAY SAY, WHY DID
YOU HIDE THAT DOCUMENT FROM ME.
>> NOT ONLY DID THEY HIDE IT BUT
THEY DEFIED HIS ORDER AND DID
NOT TURN IT IN ON FRIDAY.
>> IF YOU AND I DID THAT WE
WOULD BE IN CONTEMPT.
>> DEFINITELY.
I WILL GO TO YOU.
WHEN MUELLER WITHHOLDS THE THREE
OH TWO WHICH IS THE ESSENCE OF
THE STATEMENT THAT FLYNN MADE
WHICH IS THE BASIS OF HIS LYING
AS A FED SEE IT, BUT THEY SAID
HE WASN'T LYING.
HE CAN VACATE THE PLEA, WHERE HE
CAN ALLOW THE SENTENCE TO GO
THROUGH WHICH THE PROSECUTION IS
RECOMMENDING NO TIME.
>> I THINK JUDGE SULLIVAN IS NOT
JUST GOING TO SIT BACK AND ALLOW
MUELLER AND THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
TO WALK ALL OVER HIM.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT JUDGE
DINEEN, THEY DID NOT TURN IN THE
WRONG NOTES.
THAT IS THE WRONG NOTES FROM THE
FBI AGENT JOE PANCA WHO WAS THE
AGENT WHO INTERVIEWED FLYNN.
A LOT OF TIMES, I WAS TALKING TO
SIDNEY POWELL ABOUT THIS, A LOT
OF TIMES THE RAW MATERIAL OR
THOSE RAW NOTES ARE DRASTICALLY
DIFFERENT FROM THE THREE OH
TWO'S.
SO THE JUDGE WILL WANT TO
COMPARE THE RAW NOTES OF THE FBI
AGENTS WITH THE THREE OH TWO.
AND REMEMBER THE THREE OH TWO
SHOULD BE DONE WITHIN FIVE DAYS.
SO WHY WERE THEY DONE
CONSECUTIVELY AND SO FAR APART?
>> I WILL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE OF
HOW IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE DONE.
HILLARY CLINTON WAS INTERVIEWED
ON JULY 2ND OF 2016.
HER THREE OH TWO WAS DONE THAT
DAY.
NOW WE HAVE THREE, THREE OH TWOS
THAT THEY TRIED TO HIDE FROM THE
JUDGE TO WHICH THEY REDACTED
HEAVILY AND WE DON'T KNOW WHICH
ONE IS THE ACCURATE ONE.
AND THERE'S SOMETHING THAT
STINKS IN RIVER CITY.
>> AND THIS JUDGE KNOWS IT AND
HE HAS DEEP EXPERIENCE WITH
PROSECUTORS WHO LIE, DECEIVE,
HIDE EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE AND
PHONY UP FALSE EVIDENCE.
IT HAPPENED IN THE TED STEVENS
CASE AND THIS JUDGE WAS
PRESIDING.
THESE ARE PROSECUTORS WHO DON'T
CARE ABOUT JUSTICE OR THE TRUTH.
MUELLER'S TEAM ONLY CARES ABOUT
GETTING TRUMP IN WINNING CASES.
THIS JUDGE CARES ABOUT JUSTICE
AND HE MAY TURN TO THE
PROSECUTORS AND SAY, WAIT A
MINUTE.
>> NOT ONLY THAT, THE JUDGE HAS
THE AUTHORITY TO VACATE THE
PLACE, BUT WHAT'S INTERESTING IS
THAT FLYNN DID NOT MAKE ANY OF
THESE NOTIONS.
THE JUDGE WILL HAVE TO DO IT ON
HIS OWN, BUT WILL HE?
>> THE JUDGE SAID DON'T TURN
THIS OVER TO DEFENSE.
I WANT TO SEE THE DOCUMENTS.
>> THE JUDGE TURNED TO MICHAEL
FLYNN AND SAID, WHAT HAPPENED
HERE?
IF YOU DIDN'T LIE, WHERE YOU
COERCED AND FORCED?
DID MUELLER AND HIS TEAM
THREATEN YOUR SON?
DID HE CAUSE YOU TO ESSENTIALLY
GO BANKRUPT AND BROKE?
>> IN ADDITION TO THAT, YOU
INTENTIONALLY DISSUADED HIM FROM
BRINGING IN AN ATTORNEY.
THERE IS A NUANCE HERE AND AT
THE NUANCE IS, WHEN THEY SAY YOU
DON'T NEED A LAWYER, AND WHEN
THEY TRY TO TALK YOU OUT OF IT,
SARAH, AREN'T THEY IN AS BAD OF
A PLACE AS IF THEY DIDN'T
MIRANDIZED AT ALL?
>> ABSOLUTELY THEY ARE.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE THREE OH
TWO ITSELF, THE LIE IS RIGHT AT
THE TOP OF THIS THREE OH TWO.
THEY SAID THEY NOTIFIED HIM OF
THE NATURE OF THIS INTERVIEW,
AND THAT IS INACCURATE.
THEY NEVER NOTIFIED HIM OF THE
NATURE OF THIS INTERVIEW BECAUSE
I ASKED HIM TO NOT BRING AN
ATTORNEY.
AND THEY ARE LOOKING AT HIM FOR
POSSIBLE POLITICAL PURPOSES AND
TRYING IN A SENSE TO ENTRAP HIM
BECAUSE THEY ALREADY KNEW THE
CONVERSATION THAT HE HAD AND,
THEY WERE GOING TO HIM.
I THINK THE JUDGE WILL BE
LOOKING AT ALL OF THIS AND THAT,
REMEMBER ONE THING, THERE IS
ANOTHER FBI AGENT HERE.
EVERYBODY HAS TALKED ABOUT PETER
STRZOK, BUT NOBODY HAS SPOKEN TO
THE OTHER FBI AGENT.
>> AND ROB ROSENSTEIN HAS
REFUSED TO MAKE HIM AVAILABLE
NOTWITHSTANDING CONGRESSIONAL
DEMANDS.
WHAT ARE THEY HIDING?
>> THEY WERE HIDING EVERYTHING.
AND I MUST SAY, WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT THE BEGINNING OF THE THREE
OH TWO, IT SAYS AFTER BEING
ADVISED OF THE IDENTITIES OF THE
INTERVIEWING AGENTS AND THE
NATURE OF THE INTERVIEW, FLYNN
PROVIDED THE FOLLOWING
INFORMATION.
YOU ARE SAYING, THEY SAID TO HIM
WE ARE LOOKING AT YOU TO
INTERROGATE YOU REGARDING YOUR
STATEMENT.
AND YOU ARE SAYING THAT THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN.
YOU ARE SAYING THAT IS NOT THE
FACT?
>> THAT'S A FACT.
>> DO YOU WANT TO TELL FROM
WHERE?
>> EVEN OVER SIX MONTHS AGO,
WHEN HE MET WITH THOSE AGENTS AT
THE WHITE HOUSE, HE BELIEVED HE
WAS HAVING A CONVERSATION AND
PROVIDING INFORMATION THAT WAS
NECESSARY, INFORMATION THAT THEY
WOULD NEED WHICH IS THE REASON
WHY ANDREW McCABE SAID, LOOK.
YOU DON'T EVEN NEED TO HAVE AN
ATTORNEY THERE ANYWAY.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IS I WOULD
HAVE TO NOTIFY THE DOJ ON THIS
IS JUST A CONVERSATION.
THERE WAS NO WAY AT THAT POINT
IN TIME ACCORDING TO THE SOURCES
THAT I'VE SPOKEN WITH THAT
LIEUTENANT MICHAEL FLYNN THOUGHT
THAT HE WOULD BE INTERROGATED.
THEY THOUGHT HE WOULD HAVE A
NORMAL CONVERSATION.
>> HE GOT ON THE PHONE AND LIED
TO FLYNN ABOUT THE REASON FOR
THE INTERVIEW.
THEN HE PUSHED FLYNN, YOU DON'T
NEED TO HAVE A LAWYER, AND THEY
CONSPIRED.
THEY APPARENTLY CONSPIRED NOT TO
TELL FLYNN THAT THEY HAD A
TRANSCRIPT OF A VERY LEGAL
CONVERSATION -- >> BUT HE WOULD
ALREADY KNOW THAT.
HE WAS SPEAKING TO THE
AMBASSADOR, DID HE KNOW THAT,
SARAH?
>> AND AND THE PHONE
CONVERSATIONS ARE BEING RECORDE
RECORDED.
I DON'T THINK THEY WOULD'VE
THOUGHT AT ANY POINT IN TIME
THAT IT WAS ACTUALLY BEING
LOOKED AT.
HE DIDN'T BELIEVE HE HAD DONE
ANYTHING WRONG AND HE DIDN'T
BELIEVE HE HAD LIED.
>> IT WAS SUCH A SET UP, LIED TO
HIM OVER IT.
THEY HAD A PLAN, LET'S HURT
TRUMP.
YOU HEARD MUELLER TALKING ABOUT-
YOU HEARD MUELLER TALKING ABOUTB